i'm going to japan next month i'm very
excited about that oh yeah how would you
where are you able to get in on what
visa yes yes or tv trip oh awesome so
it's a business trip also yeah it's a
business trip oh yeah we're gonna hang
out in japan man
uh we are going when does this come out
um
i'm not sure actually i'm sure probably
by the time ax comes out early july yeah
yeah early july
i feel like every year ax it gets more
crowded yeah i can't get it anywhere
there's just lines everywhere yeah
people everywhere
uh we're we're doing the 21 plus lounge
yeah we got the 21 plus lounge this year
yeah what are you what are you how do
you get in that sounds fun oh you can't
because the tickets are awesome we'll
get you we'll we'll get you one we'll
walk you in we'll get you okay we'll get
you anywhere we'll get you another yeah
yeah but like what what do you do there
like what do you think it's just it's
just a party it's just nothing and then
we have like a bunch of like
musical acts on stage
[Music]
because like you've gone to ax for like
so many years now right and it's like i
remember
i i feel like when ax was manageable
when was last time mayx
yeah i've always been crowded and hot
and i only go to meet people because
that's where all the
weep friends gather and like yeah that's
when you can say hi to everyone so yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly but like and
aside from that just a glorified meet up
for me pretty much that's the same for
us as well yeah can't go to any panels i
can't like get into anything the lines
are along everywhere you do see some
really cool cosplays yeah i do enjoy
seeing the effort people put into ax
cosplay yeah are you guys cosplaying
no i think i should be like powerpuff
girls
which ones would we be
okay um
bubbles
what
blossom
maybe if i watch arcane i'll finally be
a libra buttercup i don't know you guys
too well from from my experience you
give off like the most like
like comfy like wholesome vibes you give
off the most like strict like teacher
vibes and you're like a balance
why strict teacher i don't know you just
give off like a very like not a
authority how do you pronounce it
authoritarian
authoritative not too much of that but
just like a very like you're very
responsible like that kind of wow thank
you
is
[Laughter]
like you're like the
comfy the friendly no i'm okay with
being a hufflepuff i'm not okay with
being bubbles last time i saw you you
called me a child
i don't remember in one
context the context was this were you at
the uh
anime awards the country yeah you were
there the last one
why did i call you a child you must have
done something childlike no no i think
it was uh he was probably a child you're
correct by the way
he is a child what the happened but you
were like connor i'm not young i'm old
or something you said to me and then you
were like you're a child connor and i
was like i couldn't remember why this
happened
but i think maybe it's because i stole
the you know we got the the awards right
you know we got there when we opened
them and yeah
i like randomly took them and then i
think what yeah so i took it home oh
what were you allowed to uh yeah
yeah but sure you know like when they
they pulled out the winner yeah yeah the
like kind of sake uh barrel yeah yeah
yeah
oh you mean like the
demonstration yeah i just i just took
one uh
like it's cool
well they haven't had like a show since
maybe i'm the reason i broke their like
financial constraints like me stealing
this one thing
bankrupted them wow that was like three
years ago
yeah that was a really like strange
sketch that was yeah because i didn't go
to that crunchyroll awards yeah i've
went to the one before then you were the
one before i think as well
yeah the one in the one where we like
went on stage or something like that oh
my god yes yeah
we presented an award together i can't
remember what award it was
oh yeah i think i presented comedy right
in my mind yeah
yeah that was oh my god yeah i did i
know we knew back then well yeah
listen as the years they start blending
together and i freak out like i've known
some of you for like i've known of you
guys for yeah yeah yeah long time
because we like never really like
interact yeah we kind of like our own
because real time was the crunchyroll
and the hentai thing was nice
and then
yeah i think it's just like i think with
how creators are we are all aware of
each other but because we're in like
completely different circles i mean
we're like halfway across the world yeah
we're like yeah we're halfway across the
world mutual's on twitter yeah yeah
basically
yeah yeah
it's like it's like a giant school where
i'm choosing to sit at your guy's table
today but i'm gonna go back to my team
the one time i will grace you with my
presence
so are you excited for your trip to
japan i am super excited i
last time i went like it was i just
remember being well we went in november
that's a good time that's a good time
that's like one of the best times you're
going in july this time unfortunately
which is like
people don't people underestimate it so
much they're like how bad can it be no
it's bad it's it's horrible yeah during
the summer oh yeah okay yeah yeah yeah i
love how there's like so many like
especially southeast asians we're like
nah we we know what hot is yeah and then
they go to japan they're like i'm sorry
we don't know what hot is no it's japan
somewhere like it's worse than southeast
asia it makes southeast asia because
because the thing for me is that a lot
of southeast asian infrastructure is
built around the fact that it's going to
be very very hot and humid yeah japan
less so but also i think the humidity in
japan is also worse than
some of the times of southeast asia
is [ __ ] immediately yeah it's like
it's like 90 humidity yeah i will um
um comfort myself with the food at least
yeah yeah yeah yeah japanese i love the
food there
caps of ac
all the cabs have ac that's that's cool
all the trains are basically all the
trains it depends when it's super super
rammed they actually doesn't do anything
oh yeah of course but i heard that uh
one thing i liked about japan was it it
felt walkable yeah yeah or else
especially compared to here
i feel like i'm committing a crime when
i cross the road here i feel like i'm
not supposed to do it yeah a lot of the
cities here are built around cars you
know yeah there's not enough public
transportation yeah like i just want to
like pop outside go get some quick food
and here it's like do that it's it's an
effort you have to like make like a
mental commitment to go out and like
like waste like 15 20 minutes at least
you know that's at least but in japan
you could just pop out
exactly it's so good it's so good the
convenience store is amazing
i could live off of their convenience
how many times have you been to japan no
um twice once was with pokey like it was
like five years ago was for a sponsor
but it was really fun second time was
with some friends like november like
three years did you ever leave tokyo
um
yeah we went to like
sorry i don't know what it's called
anymore osaka kyoto never mind we didn't
leave tokyo i guess
maybe maybe you went to different parts
of tokyo yeah yeah yeah did you take a
train that was longer than an hour
okay okay
definitely definitely didn't leave tokyo
that place that starts with an a there
no
yeah
yeah that's still definitely within
tokyo yes that's definitely that's like
centralized
shinjuku
um oh my god the shopping was so good
yeah yeah yeah it was so nice
[Laughter]
it was just so like nice yeah everything
tasted good everything was pretty like
anime made girls on the corner selling
you to the cafes
every type of meat cafe i do i hate this
yeah
it's it's interesting yeah yeah the
cultural like shift i guess like i could
never see that in a minute did you go to
a maid cafe i didn't oh
my friends did but i did not right but
they all got like pictures with maids
michael got a picture with a maid and
she wrote her name like michael with
like three l's
michael
cat ears and he was like just looking
happy
[Laughter]
yeah i forget now because we've been
living in japan for so long that
it's just normal now all right i mean
akihabara kind of got uh i don't know
wounded by the coronavirus like a lot of
stuff shut down
sega sold off all the arcades yeah
that's so sad so it's not called sage or
anything it's not a snake
yeah okay but but it's in the same font
as the sega logo yeah it's just the same
thing it's it's like in an anime you
know how they have like what donald's
like imagine like happen in like real
life it's like okay it's like an
alternate reality you step into but the
you know the arcades are pretty cool uh
but they're slowly just getting rid of
all the games and putting in claw
machines
yeah yeah arcade i think arcade culture
is like slowly done in japan
that's so sad because i still love like
you know round one yeah yeah yeah
i love our kikis that one's so good here
it's actually pretty good there's a
round one here they're really good oh
i think round one is an american
company's or not i thought it was i
thought it was japanese i'm not sure
yeah i it was one of the other i
actually don't know i don't know
it's really good oh the one in kabuki
yeah yeah yeah
they they have a daiso here in la as
well don't they lots of things that was
so random to see i didn't know i didn't
know daiso was here in l.a but it wasn't
adult all right huh it wasn't a dollar
um i don't know i didn't go in 75 two
dollars
so it's like going to japan and seeing a
dollar store there you know i'm just
like
yeah like like a dollar tree there it's
so random better though
yeah because like because in australia
we have daiso as well but everything's
250.
so like it's not quite the same
yeah it's not really cheap nice stuff
yeah i really like that so it's nice
yeah i mean daiso i've read more than
dollar tree i will say it's
daiso is the place you go to discover
like gadgets that you didn't know you
need until you saw it until you see it
yeah and you're like that's that's
genius and then you kind of just never
really use it
like it's a mop for your face
and it looks like a normal model i
bought that thing where like you can put
like a uh a boiled egg inside of it and
then it shuts and it perfectly cuts into
like exposure for your salad
i used it once and i was like let's go
and then i never used it again it's just
been in the back of my cabinet yeah i
bought like the glove that's like a
washing up glass
so you could put like washing up liquid
on it and you just like basically just i
also bought this
i also bought the slippers that look
like a mop
those those
those are something i bought as well and
then i never used them because they were
useless in the end they were useless
they were just spreading out the [ __ ]
they weren't actually like collecting
anything else if you're walking on the
clean places with the moth yeah it
doesn't it doesn't work the exact same
thing it doesn't work like a model it's
not like it's not like you have a roomba
and you're like specific things yeah
it's
it's things though that you look at and
you're like i don't need that yeah and
then you buy and you're like all right
i'll use it once yeah because it's like
it's like all the gadgets you see on
like the infomercials or something but
like all in just like one place yeah you
know where that's that's the best way i
can describe daiso it's it's it's a one
big infomercial [ __ ]
gadget place right a church but uh of
course everything is cheap as well yeah
whenever i need something like really
quickly like tupperware or [ __ ]
whatever paper clips whatever it is it's
just like yeah i know das will have it
do you sell gamer shop
water bottles
in the description
uh yeah what's your code trash tape
i think that's occurred right maybe what
five percent off ten percent off what is
it
specific percent off why are you calling
me out dude
your show
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i feel more rejuvenated oh my god